foreign
this article right here is something
definitely worth talking about just the
title alone like made my ears perk up it
says five signs that you will never
become rich one day it ain't happening
basically if you fall into some of the
categories that are listed here and it
sounds funny to say but it's actually
pretty serious so let's let's just kind
of work through these five John because
I feel like this is I mean it's it's
accurate
um how do you know that you will never
be rich
number one you have a victim let's go
through it first you have a victim
mentality two saying money is not
important to me
three you love to spend more money than
you make four you have a scarcity
mindset and five you're obsessed with
being the best in your business you're
not obsessed with being the best in your
business so let's let's break it on down
here because I I know the two that stood
out to me that I've struggled with
what's that the struggle is you have a
victim mentality okay I hate to say a
lot of these um you just say that money
is not important to me because I grew up
with that like oh oh I don't want to be
a millionaire you know if you have a
million dollars I mean that's just gonna
change who you are and we don't need
that and rich people are like this and
rich people are like that and it's kind
of like you negative your way out of
you you make something that's great
sounds so terrible who would ever want
that there's a uh an old Methodist
minister in Texas it says the most
offensive word of the English language
is they and when you grow up with those
people with that kind of money are them
yeah it creates this little false cocoon
around we don't like that yeah right
yeah and that's a great recipe for
sitting right where you are forever well
and it goes both ways because you can
paint those people to be like these
horrible people like
you know just mean rich people or
they're evil yeah
greedy old rich people or which I also
saw this growing up is they're just
the people on the hill like they're
they're sparkly and they're shiny and
perfect and they had all this
opportunity and there must be like this
special gleam about them and that's how
they got it and we're not those people
you know we're not the people
who invest we didn't get lucky yeah we
don't we don't wear a suit and title
work we don't carry a briefcase and so
we don't invest and we don't build
wealth and if we do we don't talk about
it because I never heard about it
so that for sure and then the victim
mentality of it it goes hand in hand
because it's like if only they would
have done that then I could have had
this
or if only they hadn't have done that I
could have had this and at some point
you just gotta leave that by the wayside
and go hey that just was what it was and
now
it's not about what happened it's about
what happens next and I get to decide
what happens next well and I remember
looking at I mean you had more I
remember looking at six figures of
student loan debt and my first thought
was what they did
I signed my name to that paper did I
fully know what I was getting into no
I signed it man and I can sit there and
stare at it and yell and scream at what
they did or I can get about solving the
problem absolutely get myself the
problem and that's the hard part right
because the fact is we do know that
student loans and all that kind of stuff
we do know that situations can be
predatory we do know that you can be
done wrong right and it's not negating
the fact that something happened
was or was not wrong right absolutely
but it's just it takes some fortitude
man to come in and be like despite that
I may have played a role in this
especially when it comes to debt and
I've just developed this thought in my
mind now where it's like whatever it is
that I'm complaining about yapping about
whining about there's probably something
Jade that you can do to make it better
instead of claiming it's all them or all
that or you know I'm married so you know
I can always be like it's Sam warshaw no
Jade you look at you too everybody's
participating yes yeah can't be the
victim mentality but changing that is so
so hard it's so so hard
um you love to spend more money than you
make we wouldn't have a show if it
wasn't for them we all struggle with
that oh man
um yeah that one kind of stands on
itself the one that stuck out to me was
you have a scarcity mindset and that's
one of those like instagrammy buzzword
things that I kind of roll my eyes at
yeah until
I met Dave quite honestly behind closed
doors
and I've heard how people first hand
talk about who are buddies with Joe
Rogan
but he's so insanely generous behind
closed doors
that the whole the whole pitch is
there's so much more than enough for all
of us yeah and that's a true way that
dude lives his life
with Dave there's always so much more
that opportunity than there is ever
going to be people to do the work and so
of course it's a spirit with which they
live and so if it's like oh we'll just
take that like man that's expensive I he
he was buying something and I uh and the
guy came in here and I said hey put one
on for me because I want to buy one of
those
well he just put on Dave's Tab and so I
put some money by Dave's thing for it
and I had that money on my desk that
same money I put he he put it on my desk
and he's like he's like dude there's
more than enough there's more than
enough but it's how you tip it's how you
live and so this scarcity mindset if I
don't get mine then someone's gonna get
mine yeah that is a way to
live a tiny shriveled up life and it's a
miserable way of existing I've always
um heard the phrase I heard this phrase
when I was in college and I say it to
this day as a reminder
what God has for you is for you
and it kind of whenever I feel that
feeling of if I don't get to this in
time it's gone or if I don't do this
there's only a little bit left I love
the way this says that it says believing
that success is a pie with limited
slices
and I always have to remind myself no
Jade and for anybody listening God has a
special plan for you it's not contingent
upon whether other people do what they
were supposed to do or if other people
are successful or not it's just you and
your plan and you competing with
yourself and you getting better than
your former self it's not every you know
what I mean like don't get me wrong
we're all connected but this idea that
somebody can take something from me
That was supposed to be mine
I don't believe that I think that the
only person that can hinder you is you
and no one's gonna steal well my
business would have grown if it wasn't
for that guy over there no you there was
probably something you were supposed to
do well if it wasn't for you know
student loans I could have been Rich by
now no it's probably like I don't
believe that somebody can steal like
your purpose and your what's meant for
you from you I don't know is that
controversial no no I I I I just love
the idea that
there's enough there's enough there's
enough there's enough what's for you is
for you but you got to be the one to go
out and get it the last one is
um I struggle with this one
because I see the other side I see the
the mental health issue side of this
thing I'm gonna be speaking at entree
Summit it would be 2 500 3 000 Business
Leaders I see them struggle with this
but at the same time
it's the truth I don't know a way around
it
you're not obsessed with being the best
in your business
like and I think the best in your
business we have transposed to winning
like I have to win and if your obsession
was is with winning at all cost you're
going to find yourself banging on trash
cans to cheat pitches right like my
beloved Astros did they stopped trying
to be excellent at everything and they
start trying to win everything and you
cut corners but if you get obsessed with
Excellence yeah and honoring the person
who put gave you their money or their
time and ask you to help solve a problem
in their business and you become
obsessed with Excellence dude and if
you're not obsessed with you still do
business don't do business absolutely
absolutely no I mean I gotta say I agree
with this list looking at it I've been
all of the people on here at least once
if not many many times in my life and
yeah me too if you can get a hold of
just a couple of these you're on your
way you are well on your way
um I mean that's my story I'm sticking
to it
what do you think John don't be a victim
make your money if your money's not
important to you it's gonna be important
to somebody else don't spend more than
you make there's always more than enough
and be obsessive about excellence